[Musik]
[Applaus]
poppe rain von prince das war zu zeiten
als es uns gitarristen noch etwas besser
ging als wir noch solieren durfte und
auch im mainstream in der popmusik in
den mainstream rock sowieso teilweise
minuten lange getan soli spielen durften
und die zeiten sind definitiv vorbei es
gibt eigentlich keine bekannten pop oder
rock bands mehr die lange gitarrensoli
haben in ihren studioproduktion ich
persönlich finde das sehr schade aber
weiß auch das ist teilweise selbst
verschuldet wir hatten große vorbilder
brian may von queen mit dem song
bohemian rhapsody ich muss ja nur einmal
anspielen und jeder weiß sofort welcher
song gemeint ist
das solo ist wirklich ikonografische
macht aus diesem song etwas ganz
besonderes die stimme von freddie
mercury alleine würden reichen um daraus
eine große nummer zu machen
aber das so drückt dem song auch
normalen ganz eigenen stempel auf und
ist dramaturgisch auch ganz ganz wichtig
für die komposition in den 90ern und in
ende der 80er gab es eine menge anderer
rockbands www aerosmith zum beispiel wie
wir die ganzen loses wie bon jovi oecd
es hier auch noch die schon etwas älter
waren zu dem zeitpunkt da braucht man
auch ein paar töne und weiß sofort
bescheid
diese bands hatten auch noch soli dabei
und waren sehr erfolgreich damit aber es
gab zeitgleich auch die fraktionen der
hair metal bands die es übertrieben
haben die minuten lange solo access auf
der bühne veranstaltet haben und das
ganze auch noch auf ihren platten
teilweise gemacht haben oder machen
wollt mit zwei platten boss will das
weite gesucht haben
ein vertreter waren sicherlich ja aus
schweden irgendwie mein stil
der hat so lange soli gespielt dass
ihnen mehr und mehr bis heute eigentlich
das publikum von der fahne geht und das
gitarrensolo gleich mit es gab eine
gegenbewegung in den 90er jahren
natürlich durch den wieder aufgekommenen
punk aber vor allen dingen durch graz in
der wahner kurt cobain ist auch ein
teilzeit gitarrist gewesen und wenn man
sie sich einfach mal den berühmtesten
song nimmt smells like teen spirit
kurzes lüfter zu dann weiß jeder worum
es geht
[Musik]
er hat auch ein solo gespielten im song
das ist aber im grunde mehr die melodie
aus dem song die ihr nochmal genommen
hat und mit ganz viel rückkopplung
wieder gespielt hat auch das erkennt man
sofort ist und so weiter und so fort das
solo war aber fast schon tod der
grenzschützer viel zu beigetragen
singer songwriter kam auch bands wie die
cranberries mit ihrem riesen jetzt sowie
legendär dass sowas eigentlich nur noch
mit einem finger zu spielen war und aus
wenigen tönen bestanden noch ich glaube
ich glaube die sängerin hat das sogar so
gespielt da brauchte man nicht mehr und
zur steigerung des solos hat sich
gemacht aus single not hat sie ein 2 2
gemacht
so fertig dass solo war jedenfalls mit
diesen ex in den 90ern ja fast schon
scheintot kann man sagen und ist rund um
die jahrtausendwende einem weiteren
sichtung anheimgefallen also fast tot
heißt ja nicht trost und zu jeder
bewegung wird auch eine gegenbewegung
nach denen das solo also fast tot war
nun gibt es wieder gute anzeichen dass
es ja wieder zum leben erweckt wird
zumindest hat einigen jahren sogar in
der popmusik zwar nicht auf den alten
die sind immer noch eher glatt
produziert aber zumindest live das live
geschäft ist immer wichtiger geworden
für die für die bands auch weil sie dort
ihre einnahmen generieren und man will
eben den zuschauern auch was anderes
bieten als auf dem stromlinienförmig
produzierten album was macht man man
spielt die songs natürlicher mit
natürlichen instrumenten und man holt
sich vielleicht noch einen gitarristen
auf die bühne der dem ganzen etwas
besonderes verleiht ein beispiel ist
rihanna die große pop diva die hat vor
einigen jahren nur bettencourts
gitarrist von ixquick der auch mal einen
großen hit in den 90ern hatte auf die
bühne geholt kennt man noch von diesen
sorgen
[Musik]
more than words und genau wie du nur
bettencourt bei rihanna haben auch stars
wie pink oder wie bruno mars seiner
bands wieder gast musiker auf der bühne
die einen sehr natürlichen sound bringen
und auch einmal ein gitarrensolo im
mittelpunkt wieder stellen aber es gibt
auch zunehmend mehr bands wieder die von
sich aus soli anbieten und spielen und
eine zum beispiel ist wilder buch aus
österreich die der gitarrist also live
wahnsinnig viel solid und die gitarre
wieder hinterm nacken hält und diese
ganzen rockstar klischees aus den 80ern
wiederholt und für bilderbuch kennen
vielleicht den song
[Musik]
das comeback ist also davon solo und
wenn wir christen uns ein bisschen
zurückhaltend auf der bühne verhalten
und vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so diego
show ausmachen wie martin und co
dann kann auch wieder was aus dem solo
werden
[Musik]